it's a creeper that when it creeps up on
you yes creates it's getting worse
instances just keep jumping into my
mouth hey what's going on everybody four
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even Hunter wings and
today we close out season three with a
couple of amazing guests Dominic Cooper
and Seth Rogen are here why preacher
season 2 returns to AMC on June 25th
check your local listings but first
Seth dominic welcome to the show thank
you thank you very much a pleasure to be
here how are you guys with hot food I'm
gonna regret whatever I say are you guys
well I thought maybe I was know
immediately that I'm not gonna be off so
that's just hairy week I bet you're
gonna be good
well this should be exciting either way
you ready to get going yes
[Music]
all right so this first one is a
sriracha sriracha is no big deal
no biggie why she was a different shape
from mine it's a different cut huh so I
want to start with the shows origins
story because Dominic you said that the
first face to face with SAP was one of
the more unusual meetings that you've
ever had in your life can you paint the
picture too
like what is a compliment so it was the
highest above the room and they went on
to explain something that I didn't know
a great deal about so when you have
owned a smoky hazy room with hairy men
in their forties describing a man with a
bomb face it was a absurd but very
exciting a meeting I think I was I
became quite quickly under the influence
of the we hypnotized we drugged into
doing our show and then I do want to
talk about our space because you know
this visual of a guy with an actual
butthole on his face I have to imagine
that there's a prank or some sort of
story that you can share about having a
guy with that kind of prosthetic walking
around on set all day it sucks for him
honestly and in the show like everything
that sucks for the character sucks for
him in as the actor like in the show
it's that he can you can't eat normally
cuz he has a little puckered bunghole
mouth and so he has to only drink things
out of smoothies everybody's wearing the
[ __ ] thing he can't eat and he has to
drink his meals at him smoothies and
it's disgusting
and he gets all sweaty yeah we wanted to
do pranks on him but you guys some one
gig not that active it's it's better
than any real job put on the grand scale
of acting jobs sucks yeah all right so
this next one is the hot one sauce you
your own proprietary sauce yeah mmm so
the second season a preacher was shot in
New Orleans we don't have some of the
best regional cuisine in the country for
sure what's the best food discovery that
he made in the Big Easy Domilise's was a
good place to get po boys and Shia is a
new restaurant that's
sighs really good yeah brothers fried
chicken which is like a gas station
chain but is really good for chicken
mince that I know that everybody always
asked you about smoking weed buzz it
true they also smoke your own meats I do
smoke my own meat I do have a smoker and
I smoke ribs and brisket and I'm pretty
good at it for Thanksgiving because I
don't like Turkey I spoke 10 racks of
ribs and served to my schooling yes you
got a deep-fried I've smoked tutor I've
smoked a turkey for Thanksgiving once
also and it was really quite good yeah
oh nice oh just in case just in case
thank you very much
little little beer yeah nice cheeky bear
this one has a dusting a scary dusting
yes this is zombie apocalypse and the
good thing about having sort of a tag
team hot one situation is there are five
wings
this is the bad news is that it ran yeah
little big Stephanie me direct I think
my head extra as well I saw mine yeah
it's pretty hot to know it is to order
it is sweaty sweaty Arby's sweaty our
faces say hey don't touch your eyes know
that I'm gonna make them I did that I
put Tabasco into my eyes the other day
what Tabasco story don't hear yes if
there's any place that that story will
play I think I flicked I was shrapnel
your pepper spray to have a pepper spray
I've been tear-gassed yes it sucks yeah
I got I was like I get how this
disperses you want to get the [ __ ] down
here right now yeah you know Seth with
those Air Mags that you wore at the
Oscars at all a gateway drug for you
yeah I've always liked sneakers and my
wife has always made fun of me for it
when we first started dating in like the
top of my staircase was literally a
I love like 45 pairs of sneakers those
shoes in Back to the Future reply like
the thing as a kid rounds like well if
they do up themselves yes they did they
were the ones from the movie are they
well they're like a version of the ones
that we mentioned right Bill's been
fronting they build it yeah they were
one thing they were like a prototype
than were worth like like $250,000 a
human was there with me to monitor them
yes like a woman did not leave within
three feet of me like when you hear
about like the [ __ ] diamond or
something and they send security Alec I
had a woman whose job it was was to make
her ideas don't [ __ ] up these shoes you
steal of her anything like that yeah it
was it was it was crazy
it's a creeper that when it creeps up on
you yes creates a big getting worse my
instinct is to just keep jumping into my
mouth so this is Mad Dog 357 bad dog
thug does its name never a garnish so
that's not good yeah it's like instantly
heart really don't even know your mom my
chickens still bleeding
oh yeah that's quite hot
oh man make my dick table this is so
they're so in addition to preacher you
guys both have the shared experience of
having lived with some hilarious dudes
yeah Dominic what can you tell me about
being flatmates with James Corden you
always see him as the guy who would one
day sing karaoke in a car alongside the
first lady yeah yeah you could always
tell did you swing along and yours
definitely covered with the same stuff
we can switch them down for whatever you
guys want to do yours you could tell
that he was definitely gonna do
something incredible I can't or you can
do something but I can only ever pick to
him maybe naked and Martin Starr um
Martin was the worst roommate walk cuz
he almost killed me once how one time I
came I came downstairs oh I came
downstairs one night after going to see
Martin hadn't come home the night before
and I came down the next morning it was
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] in our like way too
hot and Thomas like what is happening
and I found Martin passed out in front
of the oven which was on and opened and
clearly had been for hours and hours and
hours to the point that it like heated
up our entire apartment and there was
like the remains of like tater tots in
the oven and he clearly came home drunk
turned on the oven left it open and then
fell what is a this are basically those
little [ __ ] potato things a pub food
action plugs made out of potatoes I
don't know how do you describe a [ __ ]
Tater Tot
all right oh [ __ ] this is unbearable he
does a day one we haven't do we caught
we don't have to
[Music]
this is Blair's Megadeath sauce with
liquid rage it is tradition to put a
little dab on the last one [ __ ] that man
you don't have to if you don't want to
this is not a peer pressure situation
Dominic we're out trying to smoke you
out I'm not trying to smoke you out you
just chill just chill just chill okay
what just chill warning this product
contains the hottest known ingredients
on the planet Earth please use with
extreme caution like I tried this lesson
eight ingredients 500 times harder than
jalapeno chili use sparingly not
recommended for use without dilution
just a little dab it's very sore stuff I
know this is [ __ ] dude I think there's
something going on here oh dude we
cancer Jim you want to switch now he's
kind of Oh
[Music]
little Ajith pain it painful
oh you did way too much all right
[Music]
[Applause]
mmm uh-huh so what I quit so as you guys
have learned from these last couple of
hot sauces hot sauce brands it's where
bad puns and adolescent humor where it
goes to die so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna give you four hot sauce brands
okay three of them a real one of them is
fake I want you guys to see if you can
pull out the fake ones okay yeah all
right yep
professor fart pounders : cleaner bin
Laden and Saddam hot sauce and sex lube
real Beelzebub's buck plug or hemorrhoid
helper no hemorrhoid help left folks you
wouldn't put the word hemorrhoid in your
head cause I don't know it's just not I
don't know it's the least appetizing of
all oddly somehow to be the least
appetizing of all those things my
Simonet said it was hemorrhoid the Roman
believe it or not that is real that is a
real brand the one that was fake was
Beelzebub's butt plug but I do think
it's a good name one last hurdle for you
guys if you were to summon your creative
powers to name a sauce that could stand
out on the shelves maybe being inspired
by what you feel in your mouth right now
what would that brand be corners so
Satan's semen very good one you know
what I think any direction you go with
that have a winner and speaking of
winners I see two winners in front of me
right now because you came through
you conquered the wings you took on the
hot sauce cheers fellas oh do come
anyways I'm terrible this camera this
camera or this camera hold it kind of
let the people know what you have going
on in your life we're here to oh yeah
my mouth just like shut down like stop
preacher it's on a musician season two
stops on the meaning of summer June 25th
I think 26th is the second first and
second episodes back-to-back oh [ __ ] me
that burp hurt my jaw get insane holy
[ __ ]
that's crazy hey what's going on hot
ones fans if you liked the video maybe
meet us halfway throw us a subscribe if
you didn't like the video don't
subscribe I don't want you I don't want
you in the tent but if you like the
video subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you more than a
friend